you're working a long time yes I stopped
to watch a bird burn the cunning
Blackbird it was going after a woodchuck
and after I did you come if you wish I
will fetch when I sell down from his
work so you can ask him or perhaps Marie
could bring the basket or sell so you
can peck at her with your questions I
only have one question that matters have
you found a solution to Marie
no not yet
I look we have this basket so well
prepared for each day Marie does not
cross your path she is in the cabin
you're here in the manor house
it works Millicent
I will not banish your presence is a
challenge to tear on the land I look and
see smoke from our cabin and I know she
is here but there is no dark magic to
undo the past my ancestors tried they
were burned at this stage I don't wish
to undo the past just fix the present
what if you gave her do any yet ice for
her I've seen it this is all I warned
for our wedding celebration to know that
we are abound and there is no woman with
a claim on you so it is a clever fix
well it is a fix good then talk to him
[Music]
you